الان التطورات عبر الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره قبل
قليل باطلاق 32 صاروخا من جنوب لبنان
باتجاه مواقع اسرائيليه في الجليل الاعلى
وافاد مراسلنا باطلاق سته صواريخ موجهه من
نوع كورنيت باتجاه مواقع اسرائيليه قباله
الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان كما افادت
مراسلتنا بان صفارات الانذار تدو في
الجليل الاعلى وان هناك خشيه من تسلل
طائره مسي
من لبنان من بلده رميش جنوبيه لبنان معنا
مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم مازن اذا
تفاصيل اكثر حول هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه من
جنوب
لبنان نعم في الواقع عند الساعه الثامنه
ال ربع تقريبا تم اطلاق كدفعه اولى ست
صواريخ كورنت
موجهه من منطقه في جنوب لبنان باتجاه
مواقع عسكريه اسرائيليه الان نسمع قص
في هذه المنطقه التي اتواجد فيها فتم
اطلاق سته صواريخ كورنت موجهه كدفعه اولى
استهدفت مجموعه من المواقع العسكريه
الاسرائيليه عند الحافه
الاماميه القريبه من الحدود اللبنانيه
اعقب ذلك بعد نحو ربع ساعه اطلاق اكثر من
32 صاروخا تم اطلاقهم من راجمه كامله
باتجاه قوص واسع يمتد من مستوطنات دفيف
وصولا الى
متات الان نسمع ايضا مزيدا من اطلاق
الصواريخ لربما سنحرق الكاميرا حتى الان
لا يمكن ان تظهر اي معالم لهذه الصواريخ
اين تقع او لهذا القصف الاسرائيلي ولكن
كما كنت اشير اعقب اطلاق صواريخ الكورنيت
المواجهه على المواقع العسكريه الاماميه
عند الحافه الاماميه من الحدود اللبنانيه
مع المستوطنات
اي اعقب ذلك اطلاق مجموعه كبيره من تلك
الصواريخ عبر رجيمات الصواريخ الى منطقه
خلفيه نحن نتحدث عن مواقع ومناطق ضمن
مستوطنات اسرائيليه في المنطقه الخلفيه
عبرت تلك الصواريخ بشكل مباشر الى مجموعه
كبيره الى قوص واسع من هذه المستوطنات
نتحدث عن متات عن سعسع عن دفيف عن نوعه
تلك المنطقه التي جرى استهدافها من قبل
الصواريخ التي اطلقت بشكل واضح كان هنالك
عمليه مركبه الصباح هذا اليوم من خلال
مجموعه الصواريخ التي جرى اطلاقها ضمن
دفعتين الدفعه الاولى تستهدف المواقع
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الاماميه اما الدفعه
الثانيه وهي الاكبر ونتحدث عن راجمه
صواريخ والان
نسمع طائرات اسرائيليه حربيه في الافق منذ
اللحظه التي تم اطلاق فيها هذه الصواريخ
باتت المسيرات من جهه والطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه تحلق في سماء هذه المنطقه طقه
تحديدا في هذه الخلفيه مجموعه كبيره من
المواقع العسكريه التي غالبا ما يتم
استهدافها ولكن يمكنني القول بانه ضمن
دفعه واحده من اطلاق الصواريخ اليوم سجلنا
الدفعه الاكبر بمعنى انه بمجرد اطلاق 32
صاروخا بدفعه واحده يعتبر هذا الرقم كبير
جدا بالنسبه للصواريخ والعمليات التي كانت
تطلق سابقا كل هذه التطورات يمكن ربطها
بالتحذيرات التي كانت قد اطلقت و الترقب
على مستوى الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان
للعمليات المرتقبه في اعقاب عمليه
الاغتيال التي نفذتها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في قلب ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه
والتي ترتبط باغتيال الشيخ صالح العاروري
ورفاقه بالامس كان هنالك كلام للامين
العام لحزب الله اشار فيه الى ان الرد على
هذا الاغتيال اتي لم حاله وكان هنالك
عباره لافته بان الامر اصبح في يد الميدان
بمعنى انه اعطيت الاوامر بشكل بشكل مباشر
للفرق القتاليه التابعه لحزب الله الممتده
على طول هذه
الحدود مزيد من اطلاق القذائف نحن نتحدث
الان عن قذائف تنطلق من الجانب الاسرائيلي
ولكن لا يمكن ان نميز المنطقه التي تسقط
فيها وكنت اشير الى انه في ذلك الكلام
الذي اطلقه الامين العام بالامس لحزب الله
هو اشاره الى ان الكلمه اصبحت للميدان
بمعنى انه اعطيت التوجيهات بشكل مباشر
للفرق القتاليه المتواجده على طول الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان
بتوجيه صواريخها واستهداف ما يمكن
استهدافه الان هنالك ايضا طائرات حربيه في
الافق من الواضح اننا اليوم سنكون ازاء
تطور كبير على مستوى الجبهه الجنوبيه
للبنان لان العمليات التي بدات باكرا
والان الرد الاسرائيلي والتحليق المكثف
للطائرات الحربيه في الافق كل هذا الامر
يوحي باننا سنكون ازاء توتر على مستوى
الجبهه اضافي وهنالك ايه من جهه من جهه
لبنان اطلاق الصواريخ ويبدو ان القوات
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تستعد للرد حتى
الان ردت بقذائف محدوده لابد من الاشاره
ايضا وهذا الامر كان مفارقا بانه عندما تم
اطلاق راجمه الصواريخ الكامله عدد
الصواريخ الاعتراضيه التي اطلقت من قبل
القبه الحديديه في سماء هذه المنطقه كان
محدودا للغايه لم نرصد سوى ثلاث او اربع
صواريخ اعتراضيه سابقا عندما كان يتم
اطلاق دفعات كبيره من الصوا يخ من راجمات
الصواريخ من قبل المقاومه باتجاه العمق
الاسرائيلي كانت كل هذه المنطقه تشتعل
بالانفجارات ودوي الانفجارات من قبل
الصواريخ الاعتراضيه الاسرائيليه التي
كانت تدوي هنا ولكن كان لافتا بان هذه
العمليه المركبه التي سبقها اطلاق صواريخ
الكورنيت اعقبها الراجمه وبالاضافه الى
الحديث عن احتمال ادخال مسيرات الى
الاجواء اجواء المستوطنات الاسرائيليه كل
هذا الامر يشي باننا كنا ازاء عمليه مركبه
من عده ده اضلع دخلت فيها الصواريخ
الموجهه اعقبها صواريخ الكاتوه والجراد
الان ايضا مزيد من القصف الاسرائيلي ولكن
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يمكن رصد المكان الذي
تسقط فيه هذه الصواريخ ولكن من الواضح ان
عمليات الاطلاق والقصف تتم من المواقع
الاسرائيليه المتواجده على هذه التلال نحن
نتحدث عن ثكنه برانيت وهي كانت مقر
للقياده 911 في القوات الاسرائيليه ولكن
جرى نقلها من هذه الثكنه بعد ما تم
استهدافها سابقا بصواريخ البركان ايضا
مجموعه كبيره من المواقع هنا موقع الراهب
الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى موقع سعسع وغيره
وموقع حرمون كل هذه المواقع تنتشر عند هذا
الخط الحدودي وبالتالي الان لحظات الترقب
هي سيده الموقف هنا بعد اطلاق كل هذه
الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان كيف سيكون الرد
الاسرائيلي في ظل هذا التحليق المكثف الذي
لا يكاد يغادر سماء المنطقه بالنسبه
للمقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه بالاضافه
الم السيارات